Kiki Palmer's officially a mom your girl
is ready for the Park yeah the 29 year
old welcomed her first child with
boyfriend Darius Jackson oh my gosh come
on let's talk about it and of course
Kiki shared her bump Journey on
Instagram you have a respect system
there's some rooms going around
people have been in my comments saying
Kiki's having a baby Kiki's pregnant
Kiki first announced the news of her
pregnancy when she made her Saturday
Night Live debut in December and I want
to set the record straight I am
and while fans had been speculating for
a while the actress made her SNL
appearance a moment to laugh about I
gotta say though it is bad when people
on the internet spread rumors about you
y'all but it's even worse when they're
correct
so hard to keep it on a down low because
I got a lot of stuff going on you know
people kept coming up to me
congratulations I'm like shh can y'all
stop I got a liquor sponsorship on the
line
Kiki got her start in the acting world
at a young age with her roles in Aquila
and the Bee
p-r-e-s-t-i-d-i-g-i-t-a-t-i-o-n
[Music]
press to digitation that's correct
and Nickelodeon's True Jackson VP I
remember this one time I had a sleepover
at Lulu's house we had a maple syrup
ride then we had a pillow fight and it
was so crazy because all this stuff
she missed out
some people feel a little weird about me
having a baby because I was a drowned
actor I just want to say look I'm 29 I'm
grown okay I have sex I own a home I
stormed the capital on January 6th you
know
to do I'm kidding Kiki was joined
backstage by her boyfriend Darius who
she gave a special shout out to on
Instagram after the show this year has
taken me for a ride and how cool my baby
and I are already doing it together
thank you to my other half D volton for
giving me the things that only true
Unity can bring you already know Kiki
and Darius have largely kept their
romance out of the spotlight but made
things Instagram official in 2021 when
he posted a birthday tribute to the
actress cheers to the new parents and
their bundle of joy this has been the
biggest blessing and I am so excited
guys I'm gonna be a mom
foreign
[Music]